this is a conflict being played out
every day on social media but
disinformation is also a weapon in this
warp so Sky News we use different tools
and techniques to verify information
before we include it in our journalism
it's called open source intelligence or
ocean using publicly available data like
satellite imagery and social media to
understand what's happening this is the
ocean view now one of the big stories
over the last week has been the reaction
to the mobilization order issued by
Vladimir Putin we saw protests in Moscow
but also much further afield as in this
video and when it's posted to social
media they said this was Dagestan in
Russia next to the border with Georgia
protesters chanting no to war and that's
true that would show opposition to the
mobilization was pretty geographically
widespread but we need to check and we
can do that by geolocation and this
rather distinctive Green Building here
we can actually find that on Google
Earth it's a theater or we can locate
another protest said to be happening in
Siberia in this Square here you'll
notice this rather distinctive sign
we'll show you still from the same
protest that sign is there and we can
actually find that sign on Google Earth
so it can be quite confident about where
we are the same techniques can help us
understand more about the troops being
mobilized and where they're coming from
how far away they're coming from now
this video was posted by a Russian
social media channel saying this was new
recruits assembling in magadan's
so-called airport that's all the way
East in Siberia now we don't take their
word for it and we use Clues to help
confirm the location right at the end of
the video you see this building on the
right hand side red and white quite
distinctive and we look at Google Maps
imagery this is what you get for that
airport that building looks like a very
good match indeed sometimes it can be a
bit trickier we found this image of
Russian troops being sent to the
Georgian border perhaps to stop
conscripts fleeing you can see them on
top of that car there's not much to go
on so we follow the road road all the
way up to the Georgia border and then we
think actually that sign is a pretty
good match for that sign these pylons
seem to match up as well and to make
really sure we can match the terrain now
this is a bit harder to make out but you
can see the ridge line in the background
we put those two together those are
pretty much the same we can be confident
about what we're looking at and we later
got more content more user generated
content pictures videos from that
confirming that location now sometimes
it works the other way this video went
viral the day that Putin issued that
mobilization order he said the person
who tweeted it said it showed Russians
fleeing into Finland it didn't show that
at all actually we trailed social media
apps and eventually it found the same
video posted to tick tock several days
earlier it's just a Queue at the border
but we need to do the work to find that
out